It's time for brutally honest review of Ballerina Farms meat.
And you guys had a lot of thoughts and feelings about their pastry box,
so I can only imagine how this is gonna go.
I really wanted to try a filet,
but they were out of stock,
so I ended up getting a rib eye and short ribs.
I also wanted to try their garlic and herb salt,
so I got that as well. And as you can see,
the subtotal was ninety two dollars and forty eight cents for shipping
being $46, which was pretty crazy to me.
Which was made frustrating by the fact
that it did not ship for six days.
I can understand a few days of processing,
but paying $46 for shipping that should be one to two days
and having to wait over a week to receive it is way too much to me.
Anyway, starting off with the garlic and herb salt.
I really enjoyed this. Do I think it's overpriced for $17?
Yeah, but if you have the money to splurge,
I definitely think a higher quality salt,
especially one with so much flavor like this,
can be worth it. It's described as hand harvested,
unrefined mineral sea salt with organic herbs including basil, garlic,
leek, margarine, parsley,
Rosemary and seaweed. But now onto the star of the show,
which is these beautiful short ribs.
I braised these in red wine and bone broth for about three hours.
I wish I'd done It longer
because they were not as pull apart as I wanted them to be in the end.
And I don't blame the meat for this,
I just blame my impatience.
I did find the short were pretty fatty,
and I know that is relatively normal for this cut of meat,
but I just felt like at the end I was digging through a lot
lot of fat to get to the actual.
Overall though, I did enjoy the short rib.
It tasted like good quality meat,
but I really struggle to say that it's worth the price point,
especially with how crazy the shipping is.
Unless you have absolutely no access to good quality meat
where you live.
Stay tuned because I'm gonna review the rib eye in a separate video.